Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. I want to start
today with another Republican senator who is
saying something so uncontroversial, but
it becomes controversial because of how
radically authoritarian the Republican Party has
become. But also even though he's saying something
true and uncontroversial, he's not our ally. He's
not our friend. He's still a radical Republican
senator. I know him being kind of cryptic in
the introduction, but there's really three
issues here. Issue number one is it's become
controversial to say that Joe Biden really one
issue number two is that former President Donald
Trump continues to be treated like a little boy.
Any time anybody tells the
truth about the 2020 election
and issue number three is we should not be
confused. These aren't our ally Republicans.
They're radical Republicans who accept an
uncontroversial fact. If a Republican said
We need water to live, we wouldn't say they're our
ally. We would say, no, we agree about something
completely uncontroversial and they are still
radical Republicans. So let's get right into
it so that you will understand what I'm talking
about. Republican Senator Mike Rounds, he appeared
rounds, plural. That is. He appeared on Sunday
with ABC's George Stephanopoulos. And he
said in very unknown, ambiguous terms that
they lost the 2020 presidential election.
This isn't news to you. It's not news to me.
But there haven't been that many Republicans
that speak this clearly. So let's take
a listen to what Mike Rounds had to say.
Speaker 2: Here we go. You heard Martha Raddatz
this piece right there. How do you what do you say
you? You voted to certify the election last year.
You condemned the protests as an insurrection.
What do you say to all those Republicans, all
those veterans who believe the election was
stolen, who've bought the falsehoods
coming from former President Trump?
We looked as a part of our due diligence, we
looked at over 60 different accusations made
in multiple states. While there were
some irregularities, there were none of
the irregularities, which would have risen
to the point where they would have changed
the vote outcome in a single state. The
election was fair, as fair as we've seen.
We simply did not win the election as Republicans
for the presidency and moving forward,
and that's the way we want to look at this moving
forward. We have to refocus once again on what
it's going to take to win the presidency. Right?
Speaker 1: Actually trying to convince people that
it's in their best interests to vote for you.
Speaker 2: And if we simply look back and tell
our people, don't vote because you know,
there's cheating going on, then we're going
to put ourselves in a huge disadvantage.
So moving forward, let's focus on what it
takes to win those elections. We can do that,
but we have to let people know that they can.
They can believe and they can have confidence
that those elections are fair and and that is
in every single state that we looked at.
Speaker 1: So this is not controversial.
This is a senator simply saying we lost, we
lost that. That's all that happened. There were
not more irregularities than there typically are.
They didn't affect results in even a single state.
We lost, and we've got to figure out how to win.
So number one is that's controversial among many
Republicans at this point in time. Roughly half
of whom still believe the election wasn't really
won by Joe Biden. This gets us to Donald Trump's
response. This uncontroversial statement from a
Republican, which it being controversial is part
of the story triggers the former president to
no end within a few hours of this happening very
early yesterday after this statement came out on
Sunday. Donald Trump puts out a statement quote,
Senator, he puts it in quotes. Senator Mike Rounds
of the Great State of South Dakota just went woke
on the Capital F fraudulent presidential election
of 2020. No, he didn't woke it. He just said,
Hey, they got more votes and therefore they won.
He made a statement this weekend on ABC Fake News
that despite massive evidence to the contrary,
including much of it pouring in from Wisconsin,
Georgia, Arizona, Michigan, Pennsylvania and
other states, there's no evidence pouring in,
guys. He found the election to be OK, just fine.
Is he crazy or just stupid? The numbers are
conclusive, and the fraudulent and irregular votes
are massive. That's untrue. The only reason he
did this is because he got my endorsement easily
and got my endorsement and easily won his
state in 2020. So now he thinks he has time.
And those are the only ones the week
who will break away, even though his
election will not be coming up with for five
years. I will never endorse this jerk again.
It's rhinos like this. Remember, Rhino means
Republican in name only. It's a term they
use to mean they have an R next to their name,
but they're not really a Republican. There's a
litmus test now for Trump. If you believe he
really lost, you're not really a Republican
Trump rating. It's rhinos like this that are
allowing the Democrats to destroy our nation.
And then he goes on with the normal stuff the
radical left Democrats and rhinos like Senator
Mike Rounds don't make it easy for our country
to succeed. He's a weak and ineffective leader.
And I hereby firmly pledge that he will never
receive my endorsement again. So second part of
the story is this is a former president, an
adult by all, by all technical measures who
is relegated to sandbox playground insults anytime
somebody says something that's uncontroversial,
uncontroversial. Now the third part and this is
the really important part is these people are
not our friends. These people are not allies.
Liz Cheney, Adam Kinzinger. They recognize Joe
Biden. Really one great, but you shouldn't get
a pat on the back for that. That's just reality.
It's like recognizing the sun rises and sets, you
know? But they voted with Trump almost exclusively
Cheney and Kinzinger. And similarly, Mike Rounds
is a radical Republican. He doesn't get any praise
from us. We note that it's wild that him saying
Biden one is out of step with the Republican
Party, but this guy is no friend of ours. He was
one of the 22 senators who signed a letter telling
Trump to pull out of the Paris climate agreement.
He supported Remember Scott Pruitt from the EPA,
who was caught spending insane amounts of money on
luxury travel for his family? A completely beyond
the pale mike rounds stood by Scott Pruitt. Rounds
opposed the first step act, which was one of the
few OK things that Donald Trump actually did as
president. He has voted to repeal the Affordable
Care Act multiple times. He abstained from even
voting on the creation of the panel to investigate
what happened on Jan. six. Mike Rounds is a
radical. We don't like Mike Rounds, so we have
to remember that when we say, Wow, this guy is
willing to accept an incontrovertible. In truth,
we don't see him as a friend of the left
because he's not. He's still a radical.